احنا هلا في موسم سفر وكلنا طبعا متاهبين
ومتحفزين لبدايه الاجازه الصيفيه ولكن قبل
حجز رحلتك تختار الوجهه ثم تبدا في
الاستماع لخبرات الاهل والاصدقاء لاعداد
برنامج السفر تقرا المراجعات تتابع مقاطع
مؤخرا يمكن تستعين
يمكن اكيد طبعا مع كل هذه الخيارات يفضل
بعض المسافرين لاستعانه بمدرب سفر هو دليل
بشري على الاغلب مسافر في الاساس جاب
البلاد وتحصل على خبره وقرر مشاركتها
مقابل اجر هذا الاتجاه تصاعد خلال السنوات
الاخيره
لتخفيف ارهاق وضع البرنامج واداره
الحجوزات تجنب المفاجات غير الساره اثناء
الرحله اصحاب الاعمال هم اغلب مستخدمي هذه
الخدمه حيث لا يملكون الوقت للبحث
والمتابعه وكذلك النساء خاصه المسافرات
بمفردهن لاعتبارات الامان والفوارق
الثقافيه الزميل علاء سرحان يطلعنا اكثر
حول الاخطاء
الشائعه التي يرتكبها المسافرون وكيف يمكن
ان نتجنبها قول
تفضل يا علاء صباح الخير عادل وراويه هذه
النصائح ستنفعكم كثيرا خلال السفر فمن
الشائع ارتكاب بعض الاخطاء عند السفر خاصه
مع الوجهات التي نزورها للمره الاولى لكن
بعض الاخطاء قد تجعل التجربه بالكامل
مخيبه للامال ومضيعه للمال فنستعرض اكثر
اخطاء السفر شيوعا اولها وضع برنامج سفر
طموح جدا كان تخطط مثلا للذهاب الى باريس
صباحا واستكشاف مارسيليا مساء تذكر انك لن
تستطيع زياره بلد كامل في سفره واحده حتى
لا تشعر بالاحباط كذلك نفاد الاموال في
السفر قد يكون ازمه كبرى ضع ميزانيه
واقعيه والتزم بها واترك مساحه للنفقات
غير المتوقعه والطوارئ من الاخطاء ايضا
حجز الرحلات مع ترانزيت قصير وتفويت رحله
المتابعه الى الوجهه النهائيه ننصح بدلا
من ذلك بمنح نفسك ساعتين على الاقل بين
الرحلات استعدادا لاي سيناريو تاخير محتمل
واحذر اغراء ان الشالين باشياء ثمينه ننصح
هنا بالا تبدو سائحا جدا في مظهرك في
اوروبا مثلا يستهدف اللصوص الساعه الفاخره
فمن المفضل الا ترطي الا ترتدي واحده في
الاماكن السياحيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رئيس العمليات التجاريه والمدير العام
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا لشركه
ويجو مامون حميدان اهلا بك معنا اهلا راح
تخطط لنا اليوم
انا سمعت طبعا اكيد عن مدرب اللياقه
البدنيه مدربه الحياه حتى عن مخطط افراح
بس اول مره بسمع عن مدرب سفر هل هذا عمله
نفس عمل وكالات السفر اللي كانت قبل واللي
بعتقد يمكن ما بعرف اذا ضل منهم يعني حدا
بيلجا لهم ولا لا
موجودين
وعمل او او مدرب السفر اللي هو موضوع جديد
فعلا
شبيه الى حد ما مختلف انه بيكون تركيز
يعني التركيز ما بيعطي بس النصح باتجاه
مثلا وجهه معينه او او انشطه سقوط تعمليها
بالوجهه اكثر يكون مركز على وجهه واحده
يعني بمعظم الاحيان مثلا مدرب سفر مختص
تماما
فرنسا او مختص تماما واللي بينصح من واقع
خبرته الشخصيه لانه هو اصلا سافر بهذه
الاعمال موضوع تطور بشكل الناس تسال صديق
تسال الاقارب تسال ناس عنده تجربه سابقه
تطور شوي
للرحلات الطويله
لمدرب سفر خلينا نقول مدرب السفر اللي هو
بيقول لك تماما وين اماكن التسوق الجيده
ايمتى باي يوم باي وقت اي افضل وقت تروحي
على هذا المكان شوفي مسرحيات بتنعرض لو
انت مهتمه في الموضوع شوفي حفلات بتنعمل
شوفي انشطه ممكن تمارسيها خلال فتره انت
افضل سعر
باي يوم بيكون اقل ازدحاما شو شو
يعني شو النصائح ممكن يقدمها بخصوص
الاقامه بخصوص التحرك التنقلات انت افضل
التوقيتات ايمتى افضل المواعيد هاي الفكره
ما الذي يقدم لي مدرب السفر غير عما اني
انا لما اعمل بحث على الانترنت بانه والله
هذا الموقع الفلاني معطيني جدول مثلا انه
تروح الى البلده الفلانيه وتروح الى
المطعم الفلاني وكذا كذا كذا او خبرات
سابقه لاخرين كما كان يحدث في
المنتديات او الشبكات هلا شبيه جدا شوف بس
ما الذي يميزه خليني اقول هذاك انا عم
بقرا تجارب الاخرين لكن ما الذي يميز هذا
المدرب اللي يميزه انه هو عنده عنده
التجربه المحليه وكل مكان
نفسه من الوجه نفسها او شخص سافر للوجه
بشكل مكثف او عمل بمكتب سياحه او شركه
طيران وتردد على الوجه كثير وصار يعني انت
اليوم مثلا واحد من اصدقائك بيعرف بلد
معينه انت حاب تروحه اذا رايح له كتير
بيقول لك شوف في مطعم الفلاني بالشارع بكل
مطعم صغير مثلا لكن فعلا يعني عنده تجربه
مختلفه بيعطيك اكثر اكل
فخم او جميل لكن
تمام هذا تماما بس هذا التجربه الكامله
مثلا لهنو هذا الطبق مدرب السفر بيكون هذا
الشخص
واللي بتعرفه بكون شخص مختص بيعرف تماما
يعطي حكم مجرد من العواطف انه عجبه او ما
عجبوه بمعنى النفسيه هو تقييمه يكون
المفترض
اللي انت بتطلبه منه يعني
لازم تكون صفحتك شوي طويله
تماما ما فيها تكون سفرت يومين ثلاثه لازم
تكون اكثر من اكثر من 10 ايام
للتفاصيل يعني انه
الخدمات تبعت مدرب السفر هل هذا شيء لانه
في كتير ناس ممكن يقولوا انه انا مش بحاجه
لمدرب سفر انا ممكن اعمل على الانترنت
واطلع كل المعلومات اللي انا بدي اياها
صحيح هلا مكلف اكيد هو اضافه تكلفه على
السفر بالنتيجه والسفر مكلف بشكل عام
بالفتره حاليا فهو اضافه اضافه التكتفه هل
يمكن تلا فيها الى حد ما في بدانا نشوف
مدربين سفر موجودين عندنا في المنطقه هون
بداوا يوصلوا بشكل كبير صراحه لا مقارنه
باوروبا اليوم باوروبا موجوده بشكل كبير
امريكا صارت موجوده كتير وخصوصا بسفرات
اللونجول يعني حد رايح مثلا من نيويورك
في فيتنام هذا بيدور على مدرب سفر فاهم
فيتنام ممكن يقول له تماما كيف يكسب كل
لحظه وكل دقيقه بعمل له خطه كامله مفصله
باليوم الساعه كيف يقضي افضل وقت بديت
بعدنا ما شفناها كتير يسهل عمليه الحجوزات
لا لا مع المطلوب ممكن يقترح سولاني افضل
ولكن مدرب السفر ليكون مدرب سفر ناجح
المفروض ما يكون
المدير العام لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا لشركه ويجو مامون حميدان شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات